Hey everybody, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my non-spoilery Logan
review video and I'll explained why this is
the most important non-Deadpool X-Men movie
that they've ever made, we're entering comic
book Blockbuster season so if you're brand-new
the channel be sure to subscribe to get everything
I do weekly giveaway's there's a Logan giveaway
happening right now.
I'll explain at the end of the video, and
there's a whole bunch of Deadpool stuff that's
going to be happening in the next couple of
months, there's a lot of Deadpool that we'll
have to reference during this just because
of the way that movie turned everybody on
their heads turned the X-Men universe on its
head.
It was the most important X-Men universe movie
the fox had ever made until now he was the
re-Genesis the resurrection you guys may have
heard about resurrection the comic book arc
they're bringing the X-Men back in Marvel
comics of the Fox Marvel movies because what
happened is is that they just been following
this formula of bigger bigger bigger but the
franchises started collapsing under the weight
of itself in the same thing at happen with
the Wolverine character of Fox studio chief
was really clear that behind the scenes even
after the success of Deadpool this hard-core
rated R, comic book movie.
There were a lot of people inside the board
room they were very uncomfortable with the
direction that the Logan movie was taking
the like this isn't the fun wisecracking cigar
chomping Wolverine wears that movie were comfortable
with that the Lego Batman movie even made
fun of that idea to, just a really hilarious
idea the studio executives get really scared
when movie seemed to dark they're just so
many things that went into this movie before
they made it things that are changing behind-the-scenes
because of the Deadpool movie, and help to
give them this really crazy opportunity to
do a nice bookend for the Wolverine character
in this really intimate way while at the same
time delivering on the idea of what a comic
book movie should be something with spectacle
something with heart and regardless of what
you think about the other X-Men films there's
never been any question about Hugh Jackman's
performance.
He is literally one of the best things that
they ever discovered in that first X-Men movie.
He talks about himself.
The really funny ways when he looks of that
original X-Men film, he's like I was basically
faking it till I made it because about 17
years ago when he was originally first cast
when they were starting to make that first
X-Men film.
He was still on the rise.
He done a couple movies that he had done big
blockbusters like this and nobody knew it
was going to happen that the Wolverine character
just like he became one of the most popular
Marvel characters, especially through the
90s.
He also became their most popular character
so sort of the X-Men universe started to spin
around him, so a lot of that would just because
of Hugh Jackman's sheer charisma sheer presence
on screen in the idea that the Wolverine is
just a really bad ass character usually that's
what it takes.
You have to have the right character with
the right actor in the right movie and unfortunately
there been a couple misfires but mostly like
the Fox studio chief said before Deadpool
came out and sort of prove that they could
do really hard-core movies.
It is all have to be popcorn consequence free
family affair.
You can tell really human stories in really
small ways and still maintain some of the
spectacle that people expect when they go
to see a Marvel movie.
It.
Even though this is X-Men, it still Marvel
is still has the Marvel branding you know
you go to see those characters you expect
to see certain things and a lot of people
been drawing comparisons to old man Logan
one of the most hard-core Wolverine comic
book stories of all time but is really only
loosely based on that idea.
Just the idea that Wolverine is at the end
of his story.
He's reached the end of his rope he's that
he wants to lie down he's totally ready to
die he's this gunslinger who just seen too
many bites you've seen some of those trailer
moments where people say you know what this
means as they cocked the guns and he's like
I've heard that way too many times just
the only thing that's keeping him going is caring for the aging Prof. X before the Laura character enters the story
and he's forced to protect her forced to confront
his own mortality because as he says he's
seen so many of his friends die and he just
doesn't want to deal with that anymore he
like a glass of the idea of the comic book
adventures that Laura shows.
And like all we got an X-Men fan here very
little of this actually happened and it didn't
happen the way it happened in these comic
books.
They do find really fun ways to work at all
kinds of Easter eggs.
I know there are a lot of questions that people
have, but once the movie comes out.
We can do Easter eggs and spoilers and talk
about what's going to be happening next with
the character just a plays this movie to the
context of other superhero movies.
If you remember when Iron Man three came out.
It was after that first big avengers film.
It was sort of, a bookend for the Tony Stark
character Robert Downey Junior he had not
renewed his contract yet.
So they need to make a movie.
They could sort of be the last Tony Stark
story which is why it felt a little bit smaller
why he threw the ark reactor in at the end
of the movie they just needed a way to close
the book on that per trail of that character
should Robert Downey Junior decide not to
come back now.
Obviously that's not what ended up happening
because he came right back and Avengers: Age
of Ultron they roll back all those changes.
So it became very confusing, in retrospect,
but Hugh Jackman has made no such promises.
He said that this is effectively his last
Wolverine solo film and funny enough there
was just an interview with Patrick Stewart
reset you has waved goodbye to the X-Men universe
that I've done no such thing yet.
That's not spoilers for the movie is just
the Patrick Stewart hasn't decided that he
no longer wants to be associated with the
X-Men movies there like so many different
time travel trippy ways that you can work
him into the first class movies because there
sort of his creative reimagining happening
behind the scenes because of what Deadpool
did in now because of what this movie did
to it just reinforces the idea that they can
tell different types of stories they don't
all have to be like those big X-Men films
appealing to the broadest possible audience
in thereby as a consequence appealing to no
one to whatever crazy sci-fi twist, they want
to use.
I'm totally down with Patrick Stewart just
popping up in random ways throughout the X-Men
universe cable is a time traveler.
There are number of different ways that you
could show characters again, no matter what
ends up happening to them in any of the movies
so goes without saying Patrick Stewart Hugh
Jackman always solid performances regardless
of what the script is even in Wolverine origins
I feel like Hugh Jackman gave a good performance
with really bad material the script.
The dialogue was terrible Hugh Jackman did
what he could with it.
We have to talk about Dafne Keen the Laura
character.
She is far and away my new favorite female
character from any comic book movie ever.
She sort of an 11 type character from stranger
things like a Millie Bobby Brown, everybody
was talking about her last year.
Oh my got who is this young actress, she had
this amazing performance was so withdrawn
just like 11 and stranger things she has very
little dialogue, most of her performance is
in her physicality in the same way that wolverines
performances are in his physicality even in
his own Wolverine solo movies Hugh Jackman
does not have a lot of dialogue that she is
not the Wolverine character he's not super
chatty like Deadpool, but she does this really
amazing job of conveying this Wolverine type
physicality this raw rage while at the same
time being this little girl, Wolverine, for
example, he looks like somebody that you wouldn't
want to walk up to it a bar and mess with
he has that look about him.
Laura is this little girl.
She doesn't look threatening at all.
That's why I love this convenience store scene
here that's in all the trailers she looks
so vulnerable just kind of picking and choosing
a grabbing all the candy that she can, but
takes it from 0 to 100 on a dime.
She's so great about in this movie, just turning
on a dime.
So even though this movie takes place in 2029
way beyond what's happening in the timeline
of the other mainstream X-Men films even Deadpool.
I really hope they find a way to use her again
in the X-Men universe because just like 11
last year she's going to become one of the
most in demand young actors about it this
way 11 was actually seen on the set of infinity
war.
Just watching them film some of those scenes
that's how intimate she is the Star Wars people
want her the Marvel people want her both boxes
and careful she's going to get snatched up
by one of these other giant franchises, we
can talk a little bit more about the future
of this character.
The future of these characters, the Wolverine
character.
We get closer to the movie coming out when
I do spoiler videos.
So when you do have a chance to see the movie,
just let me know what you thought about it
in the comments below and just be careful
for spoilers since this is supposed to be
a non-spoiler review, but it was an amazing
bookend for the Wolverine character one of
the most important marvel movies that boxes
ever made just expect to see more stuff like
this from Fox in the future.
They've already talked about how the retooling
things doing smaller movies they're not as
obsessed with appealing to the least common
denominator and is just going to make you
feel like they can actually make really amazing
movies like this will reignite your faith
in boxes the studio is Deadpool didn't already
do that what's can happen next is is I have
new flash to post but they'll be Deadpool
happening next week leave all your request
for Deadpool videos in the comments below.
There's a specific video you want me to do
in the Logan giveaway is just for to IMAX
gift certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a Logan comment on this video and congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner lunchbox, Please
private message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Thank you so much for watching I'll see you
guys in the next video.
While you wait for that you can click here
to learn all about Marvel's mystery Namor
project and you can click here for my Black
Panther teaser breakdown!